hello this is steve kaufmann i want to
talk today about
learning languages
find interesting valid those
who die mathy towards the study of la
guages and he opposed two evenings that is to
ay the skin th
demagogy the politicization of the
linguistic question and in my opinion the videos
that I saw of claude hagège on youtube
seem to indicate that he is rather
interested in this last aspect balance sheet,
that is to say its political aspect
j  I had ten sages had criticized
claude hagège in a recent or
not so recent video but beforehand that
they had done on youtube
the defenders of the French
language came to criticize me saying that I was
ten years old that I I I
it was  in favor of the propagation of
the English of the English hegemony and
so on and so on
well I want to explain my point
of view a little I have in front of me the book
that claude hagège wrote 15 years ago which is
called the  French and the story of a
comb  at which by the way was served as the
basis for the east for a tv show
and so this book takes the language as
a it's an expression for him in my
opinion if i read this book it's an
expression of  the greatness of france
he says about it he identifies with with the
country with in the cultural influence
he is very happy to explain how
the
Normans who spoke French can
impose their language on the English and that
the most sophisticated words have
remained  french-inspired french
in the english language
while everyday words
are rather of anglo-saxon origin but
then it turns out that there is a decline
of french outside of france which is not
limited to in england so  he writes
the prestige of French had made him
shine in the courts and the
noble families across europe from spain to
sweden in batna he is very proud of it
then the expansion of french in the middle
ages is very good  that it was done
by the  force of arms by
the normans who went to conquer sissili
sicily era in france and yes not
cécile it's good because it's
radiation it's the expansion of
french
that's good and he says for example  in
chapter iii withdraws into france ca
n't prevent him from
gaining a fairly great prestige from his brilliant past
so all that's good it's good good
he continues in the book here he
is therefore telling the resistance the resistance
the resistances of Latin  to French and
to others the vulgar language but
especially as the international language
French begins to
replace Latin and this is due to a
large extent to the fact that French
becomes the most powerful country on the
European continent
with military victories etc and  we
see that leaflets and more and more
are written in French French is
becoming the diplomatic language
it is completely in the honor of
French and it has increased
the prestige of French i  l is less
let's say sir hagège
they regulate at least there regrets the
suppression of regional languages
st when he wrote this book fifte
n years ago because today I saw v
deos there he se
ms to be more in favor of the  to
o resuscitate therefore the languages the regio
al languages in france and then it is he complain
of 2 the fact that after the the first w
rld war where the treaty of versaill
s will treat towards that has been has been with t
o official versions an English
nd the  another French
and bah he quotes linguist à may and who
writes for a singular and absurd innovation
the treaty of versailles was written in
two languages French and English the t
o texts being equally authentic blah
lah the end of a war where
France played the leading military role therefore
consecrated the ruin of the privilege which
made French him nor diplomatic plan
that is to say for him when French
is a dominant language it is in the
field diploma  atic or in the
colonies it is very good but when
the English because of them also
historical factors and like
the economic and political ico importance
of the united states where even advanced from
England well that's it  very bad but for
me all that is all that finally and
because the English that we
know today is a language
that evolved from a
French influence and others we can think that if
the Normans  hadn't
invaded england a thousand years ago if it was
the scandinavians
when present on the british isles
ba either the language spoken in england
would be a germanic language like the
the anglo-saxon evening bags are mixed
with  the language the Scandinavian languages
contribution to the teuf all t
at is natural evolution that
here are words in French which are o
English or Russian origin curre
cy exchangers bistro it is because these words
serve the people the most  find them
useful and use them  I see no
harm in that and when he says for
example an edge in this book he says
faye for him the American
or English influenced
these disasters he cites the example of the ja
the body scan on the feet finally had
to  other organizations don't throw your
remarks etc which are
spreading english so that it was a kind
of colonialist plot also watches over
the french alliance but it the
dante society and the goethe institute
but there is nothing bad  in all
this and all these organizations it
uses public funds which is where
the problem is
therefore all the remarks of mr hagège
I find very very acerbic he was my
gang that he uses inflammatory words
to fight against a
chance that cannot  not prevent that is to
say people will speak as they
fly because the French language
today
it has not been it does not exist vacuum
and summer for millennia one of the mines
and thousands of  years of data is
a  language which evolved with the
influence of Latin finally on the basis of the
base it reached with other influences
and its 7 it is a language which has a balance sheet
will be different from the language which is
spoken today
therefore in my opinion  it is much better
to focus on
language learning as it is spoken by
most people so normal use which
is which predominates in
whatever country and
whatever language so listening reading
newspapers the  television the people we
meet and by trying to limit the
way these people are spoken that's
what I do when I go back to the moors
I'm not going to ask myself questions when I'm
learning Russian if that word is
of Greek origin English German
Swedish Latin because there is all
that and French also in Russian
but it is the language for me it is a
Russian word also Japanese or in
any name so I like I  do
n't like politics to politicians
politicization of  languages
children and young students I lik
to learn them in a natur
l way and without too much
itterness as we
see in the hagège gentlemen he ca
almost control himself when he wh
n they discuss the so-called
hegemony of English perhaps we
will have a hegemony of Chinese in a
few years or 1 1
me I would like to have a
relaunch of the Latin languages
e roma is going around but it is rathe
Spanish which is spoken by  the
greatest number of people who would
therefore be the flag bearer of the occurrence of
languages of Latin origin who could face
his influence of En
lish that said I like I am against the i
ea that each inter
ational conference must necessarily take
lace  in English
I try with our site with the idea of
the learning of other languages b
t these p
s the next day it's dirty that's what is a
isadvantage or coco common ck yes I w
uld like everyo
e  can speak well  so many
languages
that it brings us a lot of th
ngs but ultimately it's also very
ommon to have a moor in common and I
don
t play I don't see the possi
ility for Esperanto or another artif
cial language has suppl
nted  English in the short term to medium term
so the relay and common is useful but
yes absolutely learn other languages
es you access to other cultu
es other films other books in anoth
r way by thoughts and  it's down
there that's what I had to say thank you
see